welcome to this week's edition of the
Android developer office hours coming to
you from the top of the Android
developer building in Mountain View
California from Andy Rubens old office
and with me today in the studio Alex
Lucas and Dan Galpin and coming to you
live from New York it is um where is he
Roman Nurik right there is I feel it
should be it really should be live from
New York it's written Eric yes okay
which we're really glad because we have
a representative of our group who
understands users of face yes thanks our
expert so I'm a reminder that if you
have any questions yeah in your you're
in the Hangout you've got questions just
write them in or get online and say that
you've got a question it will switch
over to you we mostly take questions
from our moderator instance but will
always listen to yours as well also if
you've got an answer please pipe up
first question comes two comes to us
from moderator what happens if i tell my
credit card company to cancel a payment
i made via the Play Store does Google
only get money the money back from the
merchant or will my account be cancelled
if you're the wrong people to ask who
should I ask what was the question okay
so if you ask your credit card company
to cancel a payment that you made via
the Play Store I mean to the Play Store
I'm assuming right right so I means
you're not you're really you're actually
talking not about canceling a payment
because it goes because because what
you're really talking about in this case
is your climbing your credit card
company that somehow you were defrauded
because that's the way that's the only
way you cancel a payment and that that
creates something called a chargeback
and that's a pretty serious thing to do
if you're talking about actually
canceling Hanna you're saying that you
didn't do you weren't delivered the
service or good that you said was going
to get delivered that being said Google
Play has multiple ways for you to work
with
developers as well as with the google
play store itself to to result
situations where you feel like you
didn't get what you expected so really
the credit you know and yes if what if
you do do go through that route it is a
pretty serious thing to do it's
basically putting the question of both
the developer and the store in in in
jeopardy that's if I understand the
question that that would be my answer is
it is a don't do that it's much better
to try to resolve your dispute any other
way you know other than that does that
does that make sense team yes yeah okay
I I didn't see that earlier on the
moderator page that was sort of a
surprise oh okay so that's fine that
would be my feeling okay um I'm yeah I'm
gonna uh unless we've got any other
comments I'm gonna go back to moderator
and um next question is for security
reasons I need to ask users a user to
enter his username and password each
time he launches the app I'm planning
distort it in-app contact so that it's
accessible to all activities is there a
better way to do this persistent storage
is not an option so we actually talked
about this i mean i mean the app context
is definitely a useful place to store
things where you might otherwise store
them in a singleton it's a you know if
you don't want to create an application
contact adjust for that purpose or
create one an override application
context for that purpose you're
certainly are welcome to use a singleton
inside of one of your classes that will
certainly work as well by the
application context is a reasonable way
of doing it and so you know I you know
again it's not any more secure than
anything else you know but I think it's
a certainly a reasonable place to store
that kind of data if it's going to be
used within the session so that the
depth at W guys any yeah any other
comments on right I personally lean
toward using the singleton just because
ya feel like writing the application
kinda like creating your own application
class yeah is something that tends to
get tends to get done incorrectly often
and we'd all sorts of difficult to track
down bugs so i'd personally lean toward
singleton if you're comfortable actually
writing the application context and
doing it that way then yeah go ahead
yeah I mean that's kind of that's kinda
what the application context is for you
know so it kind of it's kind of it's
kind of a few but you have multiple ways
of attacking this problem and I think
they're all they all have valid valid
good reasons for doing them that way ok
thank you um do we have a question from
someone in the Hangout No okay um during
the 2011 go we were told that we'd hear
more about Android at home in the coming
months and that the first light bulbs
would be sold by the end of 2011 the
Android developer website still has no
reference to it what happened well there
are a lot of light bulbs on sale right
now so i think i think that you know in
general you know i went to the store in
boston just the other day so I think the
comet the first light bulbs would be on
sale before the end of two thousand
certainly has happened because because
I've managed to do that multiple times
you know the truth is that the coming
months are still there's still plenty
more months and and that we can't
comment about things that have not been
released it's good point it is a
variation on the time machine in
question is it is that's true actually
we do have it we did the time we had the
time machine on my baby was raised so
it's not the sound quite like a time
machine question right still a what's
going on with this thing that I like but
at least we can't talk about right right
exactly I think there I think we're
being baited I think they let they want
this we were kind of creative answers we
could come up with the we can't talk
about that and later and yeah I so I
wait to be a better feeling better today
okay let's move on um what is the best
way to implement a quick action like
widget in an ICS context I mean this is
not an official way to do it and Android
what could replace it so i think i think
i think i'd love to eventually defer to
Roman on this one but the answer is
you know in terms of Android we've moved
away from that quick actions metaphor as
a general rule if you look at what we've
done in ICS in terms of contacts we now
actually display something that's more
akin to a dialogue it's actually a view
that that that pops up on top of the
existing view for contacts and gives you
a whole bunch of different options that
being said if you really do like that
paradigm green droid has a pretty good
implementation of it and and you know
that's certainly one place to look but
there really isn't some place in the
framework I would look in terms of ICS
because that's something that we've
pretty much deprecated as a UI concept
and you with the idea that that giving
me having a little bit more space I
think and giving a user a little bit
more detail and those actions simplifies
the experience and so I think I really
like the change we made the contacts in
that but certainly if you're enamored
with that um you know I would definitely
look at green droid joining comments on
that Roman yeah I just want to make sure
first of all you guys can hear and see
me yeah yeah okay so um so for quick
contracts that's definitely something
that we've moved away from that kind of
that little you know dot that little pop
up with a little colic triangular to
call out to the anchor view we've kind
of moved away from that and for quick
contacts like Dan said we moved more
towards this kind of this transient
pop-up that you can interact with but
for quick actions which basically let
you just for those who aren't aware of
the pattern it basically what you take
contextual actions like for example
reply or star or worth delete or edit
okay good good point those go in the
action bar brunette all right so
basically for contextual actions on
items we've moved more towards something
called a contextual action bar and so
what happens is if you're in a list of
items and you want to allow the user to
to edit or delete one of those items you
basically trigger the contextual action
bar by long pressing on one of the items
and the nice thing about the contextual
action bar is that it can be used for
both single and multiple selection not
on a mobile device I mean oftentimes
you're doing stuff on single items but I
mean there are definitely cases where
you
want to just batch process three things
for things like batch archive emails for
example and so to do that the contextual
action bar allows you to basically long
press on the first and then single press
on the other items you want to operate
on and then trigger an action now so so
that's that's one of the reasons why
we've moved away from quick chek quick
actions but if you do want to use quick
actions if you want to use kind of this
this angered pop-up you can use
something like a pop-up window but it's
it's really like like dan and I have
said it's something that we've been
moving so sir I'm and I had a question
for you on this one you know what do we
think about use about the sort of gmail
pattern of having a checkbox to switch
into quick actions versus the just the
long press is do we prefer one of the
other what's our current stance on that
yeah I think that what we want is we
want to train users to understand the
long press means selection hmm and so
having a checkbox there and this is
actually something that came up in a
Friday review there are some apps that
use checkboxes for different things like
for example task lists these checkboxes
tend to get uh something's completed
right so we don't want to drive the
point that checkboxes mean selection we
actually want to use a bow the activated
state as well as kind of long press to
indicate into trigger selection another
thing about gmail I think that one of
the reasons they use checkbox is that
it's really kind of a legacy item from
the from the desktop era I'll not the
desktop era but from the gmail desktop
app the web app since users are so
familiar with checkboxes in gmail on
gmail com it kind of makes a lot of
sense in that case but I don't think
it's something that generally applies
right that's a good point yeah that's
great I just kind of want to clear cuz i
cal ott of people look at that
application i say well this is how to
implement quick actions and i think that
you know yeah i think it's a general
rule that's sort of how not to implement
quick action i think if we were if we
were building gmail from scratch with no
no weapon app this is just my opinion we
were building it from scratch and we had
started from the ICS version of gmail
and not had kind of legacy support for
brilliant render me like that we
probably would not object
right okay we've actually got another
question from the from the Hangout from
Elizabeth if you want to cross over
there yeah hi I had a couple of things
that I wanted to talk about actually the
first one is some grid layout I'm having
some trouble understanding it I posted a
question to stack overflow and got a
quick answer um basically trying to make
like a weighted layout and so I've got
four items i divided the grid into nine
rows and nine columns and then my first
item is at 11 my next item is at 15 but
I'm finding that row 0 isn't there
there's no margins when I actually
display it there's no Rosie row in the
middle row well it's a lot larger it's
that's not behaving as I expect so I'm
wondering if you have some more examples
or documentation and you know why if I'm
using explicit notation about spanning
rows and columns it's not really doing
anything I tried to throw a space in
there and row 0 and that had no effect
at all so how does space work and is
there are there some more examples of
grid layout so I i think that the grid
layout is one of those things I liken to
I kind of I kind of I kind of look at it
almost like I'd be pearl in the sense
that it's something that's that well
actually kind of the opposite problem um
it's something that I think it's bet
it's best to have machines right and not
people right you know it's pretty
complicated it's tricky to get all of
its nuances right it's incredibly
powerful but in even internally it's one
of those things where you know if when
we're when we're hand hand Creek
crafting layouts we usually avoid using
it and obviously that it's one of those
things that just begs to have a tool to
really work with well you know I think I
think that's kind of been our own
internal look at is that it's it's this
incredibly powerful system that
that that is that if you use machines to
build stuff it actually it actually
makes a lot of sense i think it's i
think it's tricky to handcraft them and
that's probably part of it probably part
of the reason why you're not seeing a
lot of stuff from us i'm hoping you know
at some point of the future you know
someone will write a tool to do that but
that's that's i think i think that's
that's kind of the issue with it it's a
very it's kind of a future thinking kind
of way out I don't know there's a if
anyone has any specific comments on her
on her question Roman yeah I could I
could add a couple of things they're so
so using the space that was actually one
thing I was going to mention is if
you're not using a space then you know
any any row or a column that has no
items in it is is not gonna take up any
space um so you just put a space in and
I had it span the whole all nine columns
but it didn't change the appearance at
all so and also i'm using the version 7
you know the backward compatible because
i'm trying to bridge enjoy to an android
core yeah yeah yeah so one thing you
should make sure is that the spaces have
like a fixed height or a minimum light
if they're wrap content then I mean
it'll it'll not take a base space but it
is something that that can be a little
tricky like dance that it's best to
leave to a tool the last thing I want to
mention you is the first part your
question was around layout or weights
one of the cabbie it's to using good
layout of that it's not currently the
best thing to use if you want to have
like kind of a percentage-based layout
and and one of the points on the
documentation is that you can definitely
combine grid layout and linear layout
soul eater lad is really good for for
applying weights and kind of using
percentages good layout not so much so
so feel free to combine the two don't
feel like you have to constrain yourself
one hundred percent to good lad yeah
that's actually the comment that cover
that I got from the team was a don't
expect weights to really work with in
grid layout well no that's clear from
the documentation in a particular layout
only has four items so I probably will
use weighted linear layouts with nesting
because performance with or objects on
the screen is not going to be an issue
no no I wanted to practice with it I
wanted to try it i have proto I'm Adobe
tool on my tablet and it does layouts
and
actly this fashion but when I you know
when I tried to put it into practice and
span some rows and columns and it I
didn't find it was working as I would
expect but I think there's no additional
documentation additional examples would
really be valuable um are you using it
for a can you describe quickly the
specific problem that you're trying to
solve with it do you have one or yeah so
um I have the four buttons and I want
them centered on the screen they're
equal size and you know I don't want
them top left I want them to show up in
the middle yeah you usually the way I
usually the way I solve that problem is
by is by using wave layouts and linear
labs and I put I put in is my point I
want to learn great yeah exactly I want
to figure out how it works and it's not
working as i expect yeah okay absolutely
and that's I think I possibly working
and I think from our perspective by
putting it into the v7 support library
you know we were really committed to it
we want people to start being able to
use it i think it's just a question of
getting the point where you know again
we have that we have the tools and
documentation to really support it but i
think i can't quite find attacks right
some of the tags are prefixed grids some
of them are prefixed android um I'm a
little lost in it and if there were
additional pointers or sites that I
should check yeah I think I think would
be more to come I mean I think I am I
not see no that's from from my
perspective once we've gone and put it
in the support library I think that it's
our intention to support it so I'm
hoping that you'll see more I wish I
wish we had more right now uncle there
was one more thing I want to talk about
please go ahead um yeah we will note
that I mean I think everybody agrees
that we need to have more written up
about grid layout we definitely support
it and it's hard for people to use so
we'll have to look at it some more go
ahead I have a second problem i wanted
to ask some advice about I've got um
like I said I'm bridging Android to an
Android tour a lot of the Android two
devices are you know normal sized screen
in smaller density so um I've got a text
view and you know I'm setting it up to a
lips eyes now I want to let the user be
able to maybe touch it if the text is
truncated and somehow or other view the
full content in the smaller screen sizes
where the text view is getting truncated
but do you have a good strategy for that
like handling a lips eyes textin and you
know being able to display the full
content in some way or another is there
a good pattern for that Roman in terms
of you know something that we've exposed
we've talked about um not that I'm not
that I'm aware of the only and this is
kind of a stretch but the only thing
that i have seen that's even relevant to
this I think is in terms of interaction
if you have a text view that let's say
is three lines or three lines of text
and you only see two lines of text if
you mark the text view as text is
selectable if you give it that attribute
and now this is this is obviously going
to make text selectable so you'll have a
contextual action bar to copy and paste
if you if you do that if you have an
attribute not only is it sex selectable
but the text is also scroll down right
so you can actually just you know scroll
it up and down now that that maybe you
may be able to get this behavior through
another attribute I'm not sure if that
exists I mean I know that obviously you
can put a textview in a scrollview and
that works but I'm not actually sure if
you can do that without using text is
selectable but if anything you'd
probably the interaction that you
probably be going for is upon touching
you kind of enable scroll but I don't
think we have any cases and I'm even in
like the Google Play client which does a
lot of marque scrolling or limb sizing I
don't think we have many cases where we
allow that yeah I was an actor there's
few times where I really wanted that so
you know that's that's that's why I was
curious if you know what what our
current view and that uh not as a
pattern was concerned I mean it was
really really important you could always
you know you could always allow the user
to click on it
pop something up to that would be that
would be the other acceptable pattern as
long as you make it clear that it's a
click target you know that might that
might also be might also be reasonable
but yeah I think I think the I think
getting it the scroll would be the best
the best of the world and I like the
idea of making it selectable in general
King any other comments um he lives in
CR oh yeah yeah thanks thanks for your
help it could the tiara makes me smile
so good I would like to see more people
in our hangouts doing interesting things
like that right yeah awesome thank you
very much for your questions uh-huh I'll
talk to you again yep uh next question
coming up off of moderator is I'm
currently learning android via the new
boston.com collection of 200 videos Mon
video 120 and it's been great that's
pretty good Wow anyone know of any other
video tutorials or a must read book for
a beginner I'm working on an app from my
front final project at school I don't
know many any videos specifically I know
that I have in the past learned other
technologies off of Linda calm and they
always had some really Pro like
developer videos in terms of books let's
see we do published in a published
author at the room yet right now our
producer um radome wire has a book out
on android for development that you can
find on amazon yeah it's really nice
during the Senate it's been really
thoroughly updated for android more like
he's not allowed to promote it I think
or he chooses not to because of conflict
of interest but I think it's a really
good read so yeah we've got no problem
saying it's definitely worth looking at
yeah it's a really good text and I and I
think it's one of the very few that you
can really get the latest stuff on
Android from that's been updated to that
level so it's a yeah as far as video
tutorials are concerned you know I think
that I I haven't I haven't looked at the
200 that are on that site but that
sounds pretty awesome and and you know I
from from our perspective you know keep
watching and we'll hopefully you learn
something from these
yeah I did want to point out also that
we have Android University classes up on
developer.android.com which go through
very specific tasks in doing Android
development those might be worth looking
into as well yeah we should make videos
out of all of those because I think some
people like adjusting content is video
would be that would be cool it's a good
idea okay um moving forward our next
question is is there a way in let me
double check this looks like that's it
is there a way in Google Play to provide
a paid version of an app or in-app
purchase to certain users for free via
coupon code or something if not is there
a recommended way to do this okay so
there isn't a way that's built directly
into google play one of the team members
that we were talking about this before
the Hangout was suggesting like one
option that you have is to set up a
billing server as your own independent
server and then set it up so that when
you do in up billing what that
essentially does is contact your billing
the server and say this user paid for
this item and then what you can do is
set up a coupon system within your app
so that the user enters a coupon that
would also go to your building server
and also say like the caesar has this
item so you would you would need a
basically you'll be setting up an
external authority on which users have
access to which in-app purchases instead
of just going through google play but it
would let you it would be really easy to
build the coupon mechanism into that as
a general rule if you're using unmanaged
transactions on Google Play you're going
to want to set up set up an external
Authority in order to manage them and
that allows you do a lot of things you
know one is that you can make sure that
those purchases go from device to device
because you know with an unmanaged
transaction ultimately you're
responsible for doing all of that but
the answer is there's no way currently
to do it within Google Play royalty to
work for you with managed transactions
one caveat is if you are going to put
together your own coupon system you do
want to make sure you don't go afoul of
policies on google play in terms of
monetization so I think if you're giving
away coupon codes that's one thing but
the DVD be cautious of and make
that you're reading the terms of service
for google play at the developer and the
content policies good um to follow up on
that the next the actual next question
is what's the recommended way to manage
different incarnations of an app like a
dad free and beta limited users on play
if multiply BK's what's the best way to
build different configurations of the
same app but to head that one off at the
pass multiple idks are not the solution
from that one fragment Blue Jays light
for those who aren't familiar about
multiple apks lets you create different
apks that fall under the same Google
Play listing so there's only one listing
one URL for people to go to and behind
the scenes Google Play will sort of pick
the APK that's that is appropriate for
your advice and but it's limited in the
way lets you divide thumbs up so
basically you can only have you can only
use the multiply to K feature if APK is
different from one another in at least
one of GL textures screen size or
minimum SDK version supported since none
of those involve in-app billing feel
like it's not something that would work
for you yeah as a general what's great
about multiple apk is that if you want
to you know you've got a version of your
app that you build and it's really
awesome and it works on donut and you
just decide today that you're not saying
enough donate users users that it make
sense to continue testing on donut you
can fork your app you can keep that
version available to those donut users
and you can and you can start targeting
ice cream sandwich and you know that's
that's really awesome I think that I
think that's its best use honestly you
know you still want to make your app
available you still care about those
users but you don't care about them
enough to continue to help a nap for
them I you know what's in it in terms of
how to deal with you know I get a title
that has multiple incarnations I mean I
think that for the most part it's great
if you can have one title that can that
can use in-app billing to change between
you know ad-supported rad free that
being said having a premium version of
the title is also cool you can do a lot
because you can actually use any two
applications that are signed with the
same signature and conceived together
can actually
share information and so you can make
sure that if user does you know by the
premium version of the app if you do
have two listings that it actually
upgrades very seamlessly they both can
share the same data whether that's
through a content provider or whether
that's actually through just literally
using you know shared resources within
the app you know one way or one way or
another you can make that happen you
know really really well for the user and
in a very seamless way so that would
that would be the way i would go you can
even go so far as you know you by the
paid version of the app it triggers
something that actually you know that
actually makes you know a change in the
india and the other version of the app
you've got all sorts of options there
but the best thing to do would be to
make sure that that whatever they
whatever content they created or
preferences they had in the free version
just for carried over to the paid
version and that's pretty
straightforward to do so now if you
might make my guidance there the
advantage of having both versions of
course if your app is really really
popular you might end up getting at the
top paid or top new paid you know that
that would be the reason to have it the
reason not to have it is obviously you
you have a lot fewer downloads if you're
dividing them across multiple listings
so you know can wear it can work for you
or against you and they're certainly
apps where it's worked for them and I
would say there's certainly absent we're
to thwart me against them okay um thank
you very much for your comment uh let's
see the next one I want to go to here is
to move away from the market for a
second um is there a way to specify is
there a way to specify an or attribute
in a resource folder name that is I want
to use the same layout files for both
layout large and layout SW 600 VP
without having to manually keep all the
files in the two folders and sink uh no
and uh however I write a bit actually
I'm glad to Terrence or no because I'll
be a maintenance
if you think about it uh the the
workaround is that for for your
particular situation like a workaround
is to put a values on XML file in plugin
across each of these different things
like a value xml or like in the what's
the folder is that values Reds values
Rena so yeah sorry red / values dash
large and res / values dash SW 600 and
in there specify the likely file names
for the pictures that you want to be
loaded and then just dump all of your
pictures for all of your resolutions and
the just main drawables folder you guys
hear me yes go ahead ok so I just wanted
to make one extra comment um there's a
Android training article called
designing multiples designing for
multiple screens and I think in the
supporting multiple screen sizes a
lesson in that in that class or article
there's a section on layout aliases and
that's exactly what we're referring to
here so that that migrated a nice kind
of snow so nice this is an Android
University class right Roman yeah
Android training this trend okay hundred
is very right all right no one knows the
good answer to that one I'm gonna run
but as a pleasure seeing y'all Oh No
thank you Roman thanks thanks for being
here all right now you're stuck with
just us right adds drama right I'm gonna
go back to UM handling on marketing
google play just for a sec because
that's important to developers right
well we need to get would be get good to
get some doodle market yeah ads for
people in yet I'm after recently
finishing an Android app I'm faced with
a pricing dilemma assuming a charged or
99 what's the best way to market my app
in your opinion the CPC / CPM programs i
have tested do not yield anywhere near
break even on and he says AdMob adwords
and FB well you know i think that
we're not going to try to say that
there's one marketing strategy that fits
all applications you know I think I
think that's the first thing obviously
when we talk about how to market you
want to first start off with making sure
you have really good assets in Google
Play you want to make sure that your
featured banner is awesome it looks
professional especially we're gonna be
charging for your app because that that
just means that there is a little bit of
a barrier there people have to feel very
confident before they're going to buy it
and so we know we focus on a great
YouTube video we focus on great
marketing assets within the store so the
goal being of course that when you're
actually driving someone to that page
within the Google Play Store you really
want to make sure that you're going to
generate the maximum click through with
a maximum number of purchases and also
making sure in the ad that it's really
clear that you know that this isn't this
is an app that they are going to have to
pay for so you're not getting a lot of
false clicks they know what they're
getting into I think it I think is
useful that being said you don't really
have a lot of control over precisely how
your app your attic display so that is
an issue that the next thing I would say
is really make good use of analytics you
want to find out you want to use the
google analytics on google play that
they give you access to which campaign
generated your clicks and then you can
play with it then you can say i'm going
to do a small ad purchase see are those
converting am i seeing any results i
think i think that allows you to
experiment with things i think that's
what's kind of wonderful about the
internet advertising we know that first
for some people those ads are very very
valuable and and so I think if you have
to figure out you know what assets are
going to convert what you need to do in
your apps and they can convert to make
sure you get really high ratings and get
people really excited about it and then
and then honestly try different
strategies make sure that your of course
utilizing every free possible method of
promotion you can you know it is also
important so I do anything to add that
or
yeah a little bit oh well I mean for off
the top of my head a free methods of
promotion every Friday we have a pen
game review so you can submit your app
to like we will live on the air play
with your application and tell you what
we like and don't like about it like
room for improvement and stuff like that
and in the past quite a few apps down
from being evaluated on the aryan is
sort of and their this thing that we
have set up like to being featured on
google play so you know submit your app
and look at it and people will watch us
look at so free promotion and it also
you know hopefully will give you some
ideas on how to make the appt better i
mean that's that's you know and and and
that's I think I think that's a it's
pretty cool to get on here with some
people like Roman who really know what
they're doing and and and can be in are
very helpful so that's really exciting
great oh I would real real quick just to
elaborate on the what the what Dan was
saying about analytics I I can't
emphasize this enough there's a big
difference between looking at how much
money you paid for for advertising and
how many dollars you got revenue to
looking at you know which wish locales
where people clicking on links which is
which locales your app is available in
like how many people on like different
websites how much you paid like what
keywords you're using and if they were
if they map like which keywords that you
use map to people actually clicking and
purchasing your app and you know not
spending money on all the key words that
don't convert it all like look at some
data if you drop a hundred bucks on
advertising and pay ten cents look like
that is a files and click phrase that
you can break a party to look at it and
get a good idea what works and what
doesn't okay we have a question from Ed
Burnett on the stream he wants to know
do you recommend multi apk for handling
multiple architectures say arm versus
x86 for example we do not support
multiple apk for that at the moment I
think it's a great feature request but
but currently today you can the way
things work as you do incorporate every
single one of those binaries that you
wish to support into your app and then
android does the correct thing and make
that the correct library gets open based
upon the directory that's used to store
it I think in the future obviously you
know we're at work or constant we have
we now have to a be is that are varied
that have a lot of use we you know we
know that x86 is coming along with other
MIPS devices I think as we see more of
these it makes more sense to include
that in to multiply ok but currently
that is not a vector you cannot use it
in fact if you try to use it you will
find that the system will actually have
will actually restrict you to the
application to like the minimum ABI set
basically it does exactly the opposite
of what you want it to do so so
basically don't use it put that yet okay
good to know um moving on in moderator
after uploading an app to Google Play
and saving it as a draft is it possible
to well one or more on select people to
download it for testing he wants to do
this before hitting publish hmm no not
not through google play Oh what you can
do if it's a situation where for
instance you want to be testing LVL or
net billing what you do is you upload
the APK as a draft to google play and
then you distribute that's that exact
same APK to all of your team members
through some other vector like email or
put it on a website on a private server
or l yeah just let them adb it down but
you know it's not possible to download a
draft from google play the great feature
request that right yeah okay um back to
some coding is there a way to detect an
orientation change when an activities
screen orientation is set in other words
we want our activity detect to detect
when the device is in landscape so we
can rotate some images but we want our
activity to stay in portrait so you can
definitely use the accelerometer ApS in
front of the get 0 is there an
orientation listen it's independent
try to remember if there's actually I
don't think we don't actually have any
accelerometer gesture supported so I
think I think you'd be responsible for
that certainly applications do do that
you can also um very good question um I
think yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure
what the best practices to that so um I
don't think we have anything that will
say like you're in landscape out here in
portrait if your screen is locked yeah I
mean it will say I mean we do have the
one that sounds like you are tilted 45
degrees to the left or to the right from
from whatever the native orientation of
the devices yeah i mean so i guess i
guess the yes you can do that you could
you could just use that and and that's
what developers do use is they use they
use that they use that API to the two to
decide whether they're going to rotate
or do whatever with in there within
their application but yeah there's no
not kind of built-ins way to say I'm at
this orientation but you can't look at
the tilt so it's it's pretty close yeah
if you're in the hangar I'm actually
curious what the use case for this is
like I outside of I don't outside of a
compass or something I don't I can't
picture like how this is getting used um
but if you're not that's cool too okay
thank you um the pre ICS alert dialog
that builder automatically added padding
around the custom view however an ICS it
does not do this is there a way to make
the padding around the custom alert
dialog view consistent both pre and post
ICS the answer i guess i guess the in
general the answer to this is is no i
think that i think that if you look at
the holo UI there's all sorts of places
where spacing has changed and and i
think that you know it's kind of you
know we've radically changed the the way
android looks and you know hopefully if
you want to really support that the way
to do that is to is to create a layout
that looks really great in ICS and to
make a slightly different layout that
looks great in Gingerbread the other
thing you can do however if you if
you're just concerned about padding what
I would actually do is go back to the
thing we talked about earlier and you
can actually create an
you and this is actually how I've solved
this particular issue an attribute that
has a value of zero on gingerbread and a
value that's that a head that matches
what change you want to see on ICS and
then you can just set your padding to
that or your spacing to that and then
you will you know it'll make that slight
change if you don't actually want to
create a different layout but kind of as
a general rule in ICS you know you're
going to want to create different
layouts a lot a lot of things have
changed it you know example that I
always use is the progress bar is now
really tiny on ICS and so you might not
want to have a take up as much space you
might want to adjust the layout around
it and it allows you to make much more
optimal use of space but at the same
time more optimal at the same time that
you also have to you know does it does
mean if you wanted to look the best on
ICS you're actually gonna want to make
sure you're testing it and on an ICS and
you know looking at it in the race in
the emulator so okay great thank you on
next question from moderator what's the
best way to handle the web chrome
clients on show custom view to allow
flash videos to play in full screen mode
on this applies to cases like and then
there's something to stack overflow
question about Flash Player crashing on
trying to enter full screen mode and
Android for I do not know the answer to
this one off the top of my head yeah
that's a good one I think when I first
heard that you know it reminded me that
that we actually were that chrome refers
to not just a browser but it also refers
to the the thing in the browser that
actually displays things like controls
for the user and it's a good it's a good
question um you know it's also kind of
these days I think that using flash
player within within a web view within
your app is definitely pushing the
platform in ways that i think are not
necessarily desirable there's a lot of
stuff that all has to work right that
isn't necessarily designed all work
together in that way so you know it's
one of those things you just you
definitely approach with caution and if
you're
I want a really really good native
experience it's probably better to use
native formats when you can to avoid
layer upon layer of stuff but that being
said I don't know the answer to this one
so okay thank you um next question are
there any third-party libraries for
synchronizing application data sqlite
databases with the cloud or do I need to
implement an app engine backend myself I
don't know of any third party libraries
off the top of my head in the common sis
Madhuri question it is mentioned that
couch TV is working on one called touch
DB which is a which is a no sequel the
document based database there were four
they're working on adding this to
Android if you're looking for
specifically sequel light database
syncing mechanism I'm not aware of any
that doesn't mean they don't exist
android is a popular platform and we
cannot keep track of all the awesome
things that people don't for it we tried
but there's a lot so do you do you
happen to know them you know i'm not
going to discourage you from building an
app engine back end i think that's a
perfectly reasonable way you approach
the problem but when you know what you
probably want is some tool that allows
you to determine you know really the
diff between what you have on the back
end what you currently have in the
device and does something intelligent so
really i look at i look at the back end
is being very simple I look at making
sure that you actually have sync parity
between the two to be the best of yours
you know sending the least amount of
information is usually the challenge and
making sure that those things are up to
date is a challenge so so yeah I it's
definitely I think that's it's that's
the interesting if you're if you're
sinking a small amount of data you don't
really need true sync than just writing
a back engine that an app engine back
end that take that dumps what's inside
of your app is pretty simple and
straightforward so it really kind of
depends on your use case yeah i'm i
would have that i'm not really sure
on what's being asked here I know that
we include a sample application in the
SDK called sample sync adapter which is
basically on an implementation of a sync
adapter for the contacts a provider
which is a content provider that's
included with the platform and that
gives you some idea of how to do
synchronization between data that's on a
client device and data that's in the
cloud and it also shows you how to set
up on a sync adapter which you will
definitely you definitely would want to
try at least on if you're going to be
doing synchronization and the reason I
say that is because there's a as dan
pointed out first of all there's the
issue of well how do you deal with
differences between the device and the
cloud on secondly is how do you make
sure that when you want to do a
synchronization that you're doing it at
an appropriate time on the device that
you've got a network connection and all
sorts of other things that you have to
worry about when you're doing this and
sample sync adapter will point all of
those out to you um so there were some
other comments that I'd like to add cool
cool we have another question from the
Hangout go for it yes sir hello there's
no way to measure you where's the way
for audio hold on
it seems like we can't hear him so uh I
think we'll move on ok ok I'm getting
type it's question in right and type is
he could type his question in or
otherwise we can't hear what he's saying
so right we'll move on for the moment we
haven't forgotten you um sorry next
question from moderator is I was
wondering how to do a progress view over
the bottom of the action bar like Google
Chrome for Android does when it's
loading a page the answer is that google
chrome is not using an action bar
they're using a custom view I wish there
was a way to do that in an action bar
but but unfortunately if you look at you
look at what chrome is actually doing
what you're thinking of as an action bar
is really actually the car would then
grow chrome and that's just a custom
view it's a really nice pattern I think
it looks really good on ICS especially
with the relay the new thin progress bar
that we have in ICS but is not part of
standard action bar control pattern that
we have so so you can do it by
explaining a custom view you can even do
it right at the top of your of your view
that would look similar to what chrome
is done but you know Chrome's actually
does overlap the bottom of that top view
and the only real way to do that easily
is to do it inside of inside of your
inside of your code you could in theory
actually do up a pop-up window and have
it have it pop up on top of that space I
believe and that would actually work and
you know so that there are ways you
might be able to overlay that on top of
the action bar but there's certainly no
built-in pattern that right thank you
then um moving on curious what the
status is of reducing audio latency in
the Android media libraries this has
been talked about at a number of i/o
conferences and is listed as the number
two bug under defects it's number 34 34
that's pretty it's good to know that
people are enthusiastic about audio I'm
you know I'm I work with a lot of game
developers and and and you know there
well we're always trying to make Android
feel as more as interactive as possible
and a lot of it has to do with
with things like audio latency we have
nothing new to report on that but we do
see those bugs and and so I know that
there are people who are really
passionate about audio we would like to
see that address okay okay yeah let's so
let's give it another try for the
Hangout go hurry all right and I need to
do it two ways Lydell that you know you
moved it from you can move one from left
to right and one from right to left that
it'll be on the same place in this game
so they're split um in half so that you
can move the top one to the right and
the bottom one to the left something
like that no it would be on the same
line not on below and what about like
you've got one name you can move you can
move it to get just two options you know
to give it a set of limits if you want
to take let's say some kind of amount of
something and you said the top one and
the lowest one and it should be on the
same line right instead so you'd have
basically two pucks that are sitting on
the same line yes okay hmm yeah I've got
that that's that that looks like a
really good case for a custom control
right and it's pretty easy to actually
make to make a widget track users
movement and there's lots of really
great examples you know in terms of when
I say widget or Mina I mean you know a
piece of widget track the user's motion
but it is something that you either
gonna have to find some code out there
that does or that you're going to have
to do yourself any of it in but I love
the idea of a custom control kind of in
general it's really pretty
straightforward to set up you can create
you know properties and of your own even
in XML so you can really easily dump the
control in two places and but yeah I
think that's pretty much what you're
going to be stuck with doing other
specific aspects of doing that kind of
custom
widget that you're interested in or or
do you have other ideas in mind for how
you might implement this well it's a I
just get to that based on there and you
know a mission that i got from work to
do so i got a specific implementation
they want me to do right okay it
definitely definitely take a look at
your employee also definitely look at
the Android design guidelines because
it'll give you ideas on spacing and and
and you got you can really make it feel
like it like like it's part of the
platform a lot with that so that's this
kind of a general especially whenever
you doing anything custom referring to
kind of our our our general grid that we
use I think it's really designed as well
so I know that would be my suggestion
but yeah it's definitely good use for a
custom kernel a lot okay thank you thank
you thank you very much and we have one
more question from Andrew who's also on
the Hangout who has to follow up on a
question you asked in moderator go ahead
I am can you hear me I asked a few
questions in moderator including the one
about orientation I'm change right I
just wanted to follow up on that as you
asked what the purpose was and we have
any lock screen replacement application
and so when you turn the phone sideways
we want the icons on the sliders to
rotate but we want to keep the
application in portrait and not change
the layout that makes sense Joshua haha
so we want to be able to detect that
orientation change without having I
figured we could probably do something
with the accelerometer but I don't want
to have to be polling especially if it's
a lock screen application I want to be
notified in some way the orientation is
to change well if the you know if the
lock screen is actually active yeah you
know you for you can you can definitely
turn on the sensor and your little give
it will give you the
it's not really a question of polling at
that at that point you know you're
you're not concerned usually about
battery while the lock screen is active
and the device and the screen is powered
on you know it's obviously a lock screen
replacement is not something that's
really supported by the free at all so
you're kind of in your kind of in just
kind of crazy territory there anyways
you've got to be really really careful
but yeah that I don't think there's any
particular reason not to turn the
accelerometer accelerometer on if your
if your window is currently active and
the device is powered on so I wouldn't
worry too much about that just you just
have to make sure that when it's not
powered on its tiny when your screen is
not longer actively turn it off right
okay okay yeah thanks thank you moving
back to the moderator how can
actionbarcompat be extended to allow
changing the visibility of menu items at
runtime on pre ICS devices on says their
stack overflow a action and action bar
compat how to change visibility of
actions at runtime on p 0 it should be
pretty straightforward I mean I think
that so you're talking about the the
actions that are actually part of the
bar because these because everything in
the actionbarcompat overflow gets shoved
into the standard menu and that's really
just and that just gets updated
basically I so if it's not getting
updated already basically the way it
should work is that your application you
know get you gets asked for which menu
items are currently present and and you
and you and you give that list back and
the ones that are flagged as being in
the action bar actually show up up there
and the ones that get better not show up
in the overflow menu which is a standard
menu in actionbarcompat so that that
should actually work it is there
actually a bug where is as is he
referring to a bug where this is
actually not not working
when the menu options change that its
analog that it's still showing up in the
action bar I'm not really sure I'd have
to go take a look at this i think i
think the way actionbarcompat works is
it's actually just a big layout and what
we do is as menu items are added it
actually goes and adds them to that
layout so my theory is you'd after is it
if you made a change to the which menu
items were visible that you just have to
remove all the children from that and
clear that out and then and then
recreate it I don't I don't think
there's anything to prevent you from
doing that but I have to go look at the
source code for actionbarcompat that's
what I vaguely remember it's doing so
Roman would know exactly what does but
but that's what so I think that's that
what's what you'd have to do is just
clear out those children and have it
recreate itself when those menu items
change what I would probably do is just
have something in the code that detects
that those menu items has changed so it
knows when it has to rebuild just just
to prevent you from doing that all the
time you can we could probably make that
pretty easy change that's pretty
efficient okay that seem reasonable the
guy you guys yeah I think that's what's
going on but I'm not sure okay next
question is there properly to use search
recent to suggestions provider with an
autocomplete text view I'm using search
view with a custom interface similar to
Google Plus search activity on SDK above
3x and autocomplete textview 42 not X so
this is a question I didn't completely
understand because it sounds to me like
you've solved the problem but in the
sense that you have you have a 2x
solution in a 3x solution is the issue
that you want to have the same view or
is there some properties that you that
you're getting from the the three dead x
version that you're that you that you
come charging the text version that you
want the three a text version to have I
guess I guess and so that I'd love to
get more information on precisely what
you want here but because it def it's
definitely interesting I now it's also
i'm not particularly familiar with it
with the new three
except so we'll definitely get back to
and I get some more information I think
to figure out which what exactly you
want to do in this question that was was
kind of you know we rogue a little
stunned right in just so um let's see I
think this is probably going to be about
the last question we can take I come
from moderator of the question is can
you discuss what the specific advantages
are of using ICS as a target SDK on a
honeycomb min SDK app so probably the
biggest it on a honeycomb min SDK using
ICS is the target well as a general rule
it's best to always use the most recent
version that you've tested on it as a
target and there's there's a lot of
things that happen in terms of specific
between honeycomb and ICS there gets rid
of the legacy Lacey yeah it gets right
gets rid of the legacy manual on ICS
phone devices because the assumption is
you know on tablet devices it will for
honeycomb but I think tour phone devices
you actually get target ICS you know
most of the time like I'll give you some
examples there are specific
compatibility tweaks that are made for
example in jni code that are done for
different versions of Android so and
those are typically performance-related
occasionally there's emerald there's
emulation and backwards compatibility
stuff that's thrown in that will not
give you slightly lower performance as
if you're not targeting the latest SDK
so there there is stuff that the system
does to try to maintain a wider range of
compatibility so it's always best if you
can target the latest i think that there
may be certain aspects of hollow that
you can take advantage of only with
target SDK 14 as well but I'm not or
higher but I'm not completely sure but
as a general rule on you know if you're
if you're going to target I see if
you're going to target ICS you know
you're gonna you're going to end up with
the best running application on ICS
and really if you're testing already on
ICS are fairly limited reason to not
target it so i think that's that's
probably the best answer but i'd love to
have so i'd love to get more specifics
mm-hmm okay mr. producer do we have time
for one more we do have Andrew on he
hang out who has he wants to follow up
on a question yet last week so if you've
got a moment let's let's see if he can
okay go ahead yeah that's very good
multiple cracks hello again and I live
what are your immune so that's our that
wait try again go ahead hello Oh still
muted one of us is muted there however
now okay that's better important alright
so I had a question a few weeks ago
about the status bar at the bottom on
tablet devices and how the the back
button and the home button and on the
left side and the time on the right side
is interfering so in this particular app
situation i'm talking about it's a
handwriting note-taking app so you're
actually writing on the screen so your
arm if you're right-handed rests on the
bottom right side of the screen and then
causes the users to open up the status
of a notification part and left-handed
users often hit the back button so I'm
wondering if there's a way I asked a few
weeks ago if there's a way to make that
go wet make the status bar hidden and
bring it back some other way and the
response was an ice cream sandwich there
is that capability but as soon as you
interact with the screen it comes back
yeah and actually in actually the in Ice
Cream Sandwich on tablets they won't
actually make it go away but it will
very nicely make it stop interacting her
one click you know honestly if this is a
really important feature to your app um
I would do something a little crazy and
I would actually well okay it all
depends if you're using the framework
this is tricky you could render your app
upside down and force it and
that's one that's one way of doing it
and you know fix the orientation but
actually render the app upside down
which will put the action bar on the top
if handwriting is really really
important that's that's one way of doing
it obviously there's not a lot of
support for that you can definitely use
so it since your target if you're
targeting you know Isis and honeycomb
you can actually use with the properties
to rotate everything to make sure you
know diet everything's actually turned
upside down when it's when it's being
laid out so that actually that's that's
one way of doing it you know honestly
that's a lot of work I don't think
there's a good way to just rotate the
display you know for a game if you're as
a game developer and you were actually
just using OpenGL it's really trivial
it's a little harder when you're
actually writing writing an app but if
you're doing a custom view for a lot of
it you know that then it might it might
be easy but at least gets that on the
top the other option of course would be
to use portrait mode and put it on to
the side you know and you know cuz
obviously your app isn't technically
required to render itself matching and
your case is one of those weird random
cases and where it might actually make
more sense to not to not actually use
the default orientation you know
obviously not every device in the world
can be rotated some devices are an HDMI
you know that's to say no this is this
is something that's that that's you know
definitely on the side of hacky but if
it's really required to you know to
prevent people from from from touching
that bar during handwriting it might
actually make sense for your app is
there a way to flip an activity to just
a right make this activity draw upside
down no that's the thing is if there's a
lot of work involved with this that's I
mean I I you click know there are ways
to flip a canvas around and you could
actually basically in ondraw when you
first get the canvas you could you could
provide you could you could refer to
transform on it that would probably do
most of what you wanted it to do you
could certainly play with that but then
your touches are all going to be off
like it's it's it's not either it's you
got you have to make sure you're also
transforming all of that it would be
tricky and it's kind of hacky
but you know that's that's the only way
i can think of doing it up doing it in
it in a compatible way you know in and
and you know that's at least it gets it
off out of the out of the out of the
users way but that is that is the one
issue with having that there is it is if
you are resting your hands on it you
could actually touch it if I could make
a suggestion one of the things that I
thought of just for future development
is if there could be a late actually I
know part of the problem of making it
having a nap be allowed to tell that to
disappear is that then the user on
devices they don't have buttons has no
way of doing anything anyway they have
to trust that app but if there would be
I think every device has to have a power
button so just an idea I've had is to
allow the app to make the status bar go
away the navigation bar go away and have
the power button press to the power
button bring it back or some variation
on that yeah I you know I think I think
that um you know I think either a lot of
ways in which this could solve you could
allow the user to lock the bar you could
allow the user to move the bar to the
top of the screen themselves you know
configure the device you know I think
they I think that those are all things
that you know have advantages and
disadvantages the power thing that you
know it certainly has been has been
discussed and I would love to see
something that God happened but you know
that's you know I think that I think
that for the for the vast majority of
applications the advantage of always
having consistent way to get out of it
over over is more important than than
the cases in which it doesn't help and
you know I think I think the key thing
is just to try to make sure we service
those cases better and going forward but
yeah I definitely I definitely I
definitely see both sides of this issue
and they've been you know certainly
hotly discussed internally yeah this
theory we're not we're not unaware of
that but I think that right now the
general feeling is that you know giving
the users that confidence that they
always have the ability to back out and
always have the ability to go home
switch apps is is you know outweighs the
benefit of being able to to the round
and the accessibility of that feature as
well so you have the current card the
best trick I thing to do best thing I
can come up with now is to use the trek
that you can lay out your app that in a
way that doesn't actually match the
screen orientation but it's not it's not
a perfect solution I agree thank you
thank you again Andrew um looks like
we've run over for today we've been
having so much fun so I'd like to thank
you all for sending your questions in I
like to thank our experts here for
joining in and trying to give answers
and to Roman who's in New York aunt or
producer reto Meier and we will see you
again next week